you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video
eight from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and we're going to have a look
at how to successfully promote upon and
how to defend against an opponent trying
to promote their pawn before I get into
these details there's an important term
that I'd like to first share with you
it's opposition opposition in chess is a
certain relationship between the Kings a
certain positioning of the Kings in this
position it's white to move if the King
plays to f4 it's said that white has
taken opposition one way to view
opposition in this particular case is
that when you take opposition you are
taking away advancing squares from the
enemy King you're not allowing the enemy
King to enter your position to use a
basketball analogy this would be similar
to boxing your opponent out when you
take opposition you are essentially
boxing your opponent out not allowing
them to enter your position the main
purpose of doing this the main purpose
of taking opposition in chess is so that
you can next enter your opponent's
position you can next outflank the enemy
King so with black being on move here if
he plays to e6 we can now move into the
black position we can move forward make
progress we can el flank the enemy King
in this case by playing King to g5
similarly if the King plays here we can
play King to e5 we're out flanking the
enemy King if the King goes straight
back we can once again take opposition
moving forward making progress similar
case like this and he only had one other
option we would take opposition like so
now there are many different forms of
opposition but the only one we really
need to be concerned with when it comes
time to promote upon is this one right
here the one where we position our King
such that both Kings are now on the same
file with exactly one square separating
them now we'll see how this ties in soon
enough but first well let's have a look
at some examples here first working with
a rook pawn let's see how we can try to
successfully prone upon and that's on a
rook file the a or H file unfortunately
we cannot for as long as the defending
side doesn't do anything crazy like run
away from this promotion square if
you're the defending side here and your
opponent has a pawn that's on the rook
file all you need to do all you need to
do is go to the corner and stay near the
corner and it will turn out to be a drop
now let's see why this is the case
doesn't matter how exactly white moves
their King and pun with other file pawns
it will matter as we will soon see but
there's just not going to be a way to
successfully push through and promote
this pawn you'll notice after King here
it's white being on move what can he do
if he plays here at stalemate and if he
moves anywhere else it allows King takes
pawn and that's basically the end result
when player tries to promote a rook pawn
it'll end up in stalemate or you're just
going to win the pun now the ones that
are a bit more involved are knight pawns
bishop on center pawns these pawns here
any pawns on these highlighted squares
you can push through and promote
successfully but you need to be a bit
delicate about how exactly you move
about your king and your pawn the king
it's important to realize he's the he's
the leader of the game he's the general
of the game the leader of the game he
should take a leader role when trying to
promote the pun or in other words he
should be out in front of the pawn and
only then should the pawn follow now why
is this so important why is it important
for the King to play this leader role
well let's suppose that he doesn't let's
say that the pawn is the one who leads
the way let's see now how we can
successfully defend on the black side
this position will turn out to be a draw
for as long as the defending side knows
what he's doing
so what we do as the defending side here
we simply approach the pawn we want to
get right in front of the pun not allow
this white King to get out
in front of it and eventually there's
going to be this point here where when
you're the defending side you're going
to need to retreat at some point and
when you need to retreat retreat to a
square that's on the same file as this
pawn so in this case right here just
play king d6 everything is just
following that one rule of thumb you'll
have no issues in defending against an
opponent trying to promote their pawn if
the king is not out in front of the pawn
and you're forced to be retreating at
some stage retreat to a square that's on
the same file as the pawn after king b6
king c4 what does black do now he takes
opposition if he's going somewhere else
like here the white king is allowed to
get out in front of this pawn so black
takes opposition does not allow the
white king to enter the black position
the pawn pushes black stays in front
once again he has to retreat at this
point retreating to square on the same
files the pawn king a seven takes
opposition and one last time he must
retreat and this is especially important
right here King to b8 is the only move
that will draw the position going here
or here will result in a loss we'll have
a look at that but why is king to b8 the
way to hold the draw in this position
well after king c6 yet again black takes
opposition after check King b8 what to
do king b6 is stalemate any other King
move King takes pawn and this is a drop
if the King did not go to b8 here if he
goes to c8 this allows white to take
opposition or if he went to a8 this
allows white to go to a6 in both cases
what's going to happen is that the black
King will not have that he will not get
stalemated he'll have to come out here
and then you can move up and promote
next and mate will follow soon
thereafter so the main point here is
that the pawn should not be the leader
if that is the case get your King in
front of the pawn if you must retreat
retreat to a square that's on the same
file as the pawn and you'll be able to
hold a draw
end up being stalemate or you'll end up
winning the pun okay now let's see how
we can successfully promote a pond okay
we're going to still work here with this
night pond this B pond and we want the
King to play this leader role in fact
I'm going to give you a quick preview
here this is a this is the ideal setup
that we want when we're working with a
beep on this is where we want the
positioning of our king and pond just
giving you a quick preview here we want
to establish our King on this square
right here or in other words two squares
from the promotion Square and we want
the pond right behind the King if we're
working with the C pawn it would look
like this d e f and G take note of these
positions here if you can get this
position right here it does not matter
whose move it is it does not matter
where the enemy king is you are the
winning side you will be able to win the
position okay now we're going to see
that in action let's see how we can now
successfully promote a knight pawn we
get our king out in front we have taken
opposition with this last move after
king to c6 we can look to do what next
we can look to outflank our opponent
King to a5 does just that king c7 king
b5 we're not taking opposition with this
move but in fact black on their next
move is taking opposition but that is
okay
we do have a pond that we could be
moving you'll notice after this last
move pawn to b4 it is as if we just
moved our came to the be 5 square and
took opposition back okay so what we're
going to do next is outflank our
opponent and we've already done we've
already positioned our King exactly
where we wanted him from the beginning
two squares away from that queening
square we next move our pond right up
behind our King and what to do next
well the knight pawns some of you may
not know this some experienced players
who
maybe I may be watching this right now
may not be aware of some little tricks
involved with the night pons the B and G
pons when it comes to this position here
it may appear that you can go in either
direction go here here get out of the
pons way and then push but the only one
that will win is the one that moves that
has your king moving towards the edge so
this is the winning method playing your
king to a six what you really want to do
next is get to the a seven square so you
can push three times and be defending
the pawn on those three scope on those
three squares with your king so for
example if King here or King here you
would play King a seven and then push
through the only way to stop white from
playing here is King to eight you push
your pawn push again
and eventually you're able to get to
that Square and successfully promote now
why do you have to be a little bit
delicate when it comes time for the B or
G pawns why is it so important you go in
this direction and not over here well
now here's a clever way that you can try
to hold a draw if you're the defending
side here and your opponent has a night
pawn that they're trying to promote if
they play King here this is a sneaky
move King a7 which is tempting white to
do something that's quite popular which
is to push the pawn with check however
this move here will now result in a drop
after King to a eight now what if King
here this is Stanley
and if pawn push came to b8 does this
look familiar
after King b6 it's stalemate any other
move allows King takes pawn it's very
important when you're working with
Knight pawns in particular there is this
stalemate resource that the defending
side can have it's important that if you
are in this position right here where
the Kings are lined up and it's your
turn to move the king the King and pawn
side turn to move if you play here this
is not the one this is not the winning
way you need to go to the edge of the
board and only then push your pawn
through
okay if it was the case in this position
right here if the black King was on this
square for example let me just change
the move order a little bit let's say
after this move the King went to the
corner King played here suppose it got
to this position and the King was on
this Square we would simply play here
push with check push with check push
with check and actually there's a very
quick mate and if the King went in
another direction at this point right
here King c8 well we would outflank our
opponent push three times and you're
just not stopping him okay now let's
have a look at one last example working
with a center pawn this one right here
once again King should play the
leadership role the leader role getting
out in front of the pawn this last move
here is taking opposition taking
opposition once more we're looking to
next outflank our opponent we've done
just that
taking opposition outflanking we've
already established with the King
movements alone sometimes this can
happen where you just get your King
right up to this ideal square two
squares away from that promotion square
we now push our pond right up and in
this particular case when you're working
with the CDE or F pawns it will not
matter in which direction you go with
the King so I'll pick your favorite one
here's sufficient if the King plays here
you step up and then you're ready to
push through and if the if you go here
and the King plays here once again you
would go to this square right here and
push through and what else is there
after King here the timing will be
perfect you push push and then you get
your King here and finally promote now
what we just looked at is something
that's very simplified of course the
game starts out in which s starts out we
can say where both players have 39
points each we have eight pawns that's
eight points there's four minor pieces
each side has four minor pieces so
that's another 12 the rooks are
in total and the queen is nine so we got
8 12 10 and 9 39 points apiece what
we're looking at right here is an
example of one point two zero points now
there's an important strategy in chess
that we can take away from knowing this
ending knowing this very simplified
position which is to say that if you're
up material during the course of a game
if you're let's say up a pawn or two the
good general principle is to make even
exchanges trade night for Knight Bishop
for Bishop rook for rook pawn for pawn
queen for Queen keep narrowing it down
chipping away from this 39 to 39 let's
say ratio and eventually if you're
getting down to a one point two zero
point we know how to win this so a
general principle is that if you are
again up material feel free to make even
exchanges because we are now tending
towards this type of an ending one where
we are just up upon and we could push
through successfully and on the flip
side of things another strategy will be
if you happen to be down material if
you're down upon or two or maybe even a
piece maybe you're no longer as welcome
to even exchanges throughout the course
of a game so keep these ideas in mind
and I think will be very useful in your
game it will most certainly be useful
when playing the game okay so that's all
for this video as always I hope you got
something out of it and I will catch you
in video 9 take care bye
you